starting off this hour is gonna be
Darren in New Mexico hi Darren how are
you I'm good
thanks for taking my call sure I
somebody asked me a question that I
didn't really know how to answer I
invest in my 401k through work and 401k
you know mutual funds have a lot of
companies in them and a question was how
do I justify investing in that if I
don't really know that maybe some of the
companies are involved in things that I
don't support like gambling or abortion
or you know things that are immoral okay
well it's kind of like saying see when
you buy in a when you want a mutual when
you buy a mutual fund and the mutual
fund buys a share of stock in XYZ
company that is engaged in something you
don't agree with okay that [ __ ] when
they buy that share of stock they don't
buy it from that company they buy it
from another investor that is selling it
so that company is in no way profiting
from you investing in that mutual fund
that company's not getting any of your
money you understand you're not
supported you're not supporting it's
like saying I bought a used Chevrolet I
won't buy used Chevrolet from you
because I'm mad at Chevrolet like that
damage is Chevrolet in some way doesn't
they don't even come up now buying a new
one from them would be understandable if
you were mad at Chevrolet you wouldn't
do that right but me not buying a used
one from you is not buying a share of
stock and Home Depot from you because
I'm mad at Home Depot
it didn't affect Home Depot they don't
care they're not getting the money in
the transaction at all now there is a
question if you want to get that
technical about it there is a question
then of are you profiting from some of
the things that
that company is doing that they make a
profit on that you're not proud of yes
you would be now that that that point
would be accurate now there's two ways
to that I've addressed that in my own
life one is you can choose to buy mutual
funds that are called clean funds where
they go through and they either are
picking companies that match a
politically correct narrative like for
instance that they don't buy a company
that in some way messes up the
environment in their view or something
like that or there are clean funds that
are on the religious lines more of the
things you were mentioning like abortion
or pornography or alcohol or tobacco or
whatever and the best-known one of those
is a fund that has done pretty well that
that does not buy companies that invest
in quotes in unquote that it's called
the Timothy fund out of Atlanta and the
Timothy Fund has done a good job with it
and they have actually gotten good rates
of return a lot of the politically
correct funds have not done very well I
don't know of one of those that's
actually gotten good rates of return
okay now that's one thing that's one
thing you can do now the second way you
can do is number one you understand the
first thing I was talking about is
buying a you'l Chevrolet doesn't affect
Chevrolet it affects the guy you're not
buying it from so that's you're not
really profiting them but you could be
profiting from that however if you're
gonna start doing that in your life if
you're going to get that knit see in
your life that the hundred dollars that
you put in your 401k out of that 22
cents ends up that you make some money
off of the sale of a tobacco product
somewhere down in there then you pretty
well need to stop shopping at your local
grocery store because they got playboy
and wine in there you pretty well need
to shut down your banking arrangement
because most of them support the United
Way which is a big supporter of Planned
Parenthood and so you pretty well can't
do business with your bank because
they're using some of those profits to
do that you really can't walk around out
here in society without
coming in contact with the society as
part of the problem and it's not so I
think God will judge in my opinion the
intent of our heart and I'm not going to
directly invest in something that I'm
trying to make money off of someone
being harmed I will never do that but
but I'm also not going to get down into
the legalism of every little tiny thing
trying to figure out how I can just live
in a cocoon somewhere spiritually and
I'm just fine
I'm not worried about it but I'm you
know but you if you're worried about it
you can go the route of like the Timothy
plan if you if you want to do that but
you really need to stop shopping at your
local grocery store and you need to quit
banking and you need to quit buying gas
and you need to quit I mean just name it
because everywhere you deal with you're
dealing with somebody it's interacting
with one of those things and you're
supporting them or giving them profit in
order to buy more cigarettes to sell
them to somebody or Kansas goal to sell
them somebody what it is you're upset
about right and so you know you've just
got a that's again I'm not going to
invest directly in one of those
businesses I'm not going to profit
directly from one of those businesses
but the minutia that I make with two
hundred stocks in my mutual fund if five
of them have a percentage of their
product line that I'm not proud of and
that I wouldn't personally believe in I
can't I can't comb enough tangles out of
my hair to get there so I just I just I
just move on and and that's that's how I
that's all look at it but it's a really
good discussion there the whole concept
is called values based investing and you
can read about it there's some people
that do have some software out or I
think he's still out there where they
put a red yellow green on a fund and say
this fund is largely full of sin stocks
it's a red okay or it's not hardly got
any in it but it's got a little in it
it's a green it's kind of in the middle
of to yellow you know they they'll write
them for you and that kind of stuff so
to the extent you're concerned about it
you can spend more energy time money on
that and it's it's worth reading about
it's a valid concern I'm not blowing it
off but that's how I've you asked me how
I've walked through it and that's how
I've think that's how I've walked
through it that's the process now we
great blog post about it okay good
that's good news yeah but James says so
check that out all right open phones at
triple 8 8 to 5 5 to 2 5 I kind of went
through that stage too I mean when I
first got when I met God as an adult so
when I first met God as an adult there's
no fair see quite like a young Pharisee
right and so I was like into every
little jot and tiddle every little thing
had to be perfect and clean and I wasn't
going to intersect with anything
anywhere with anybody but I pretty well
figured out that you know I just I'm
walking in a lot of Liberty and a lot of
grace and I want to hang out with people
that don't necessarily know God and I
don't usually find them in those
perfectly clean places and by the way
those perfectly clean places generally
aren't perfectly clean when you get in
there so just you know just an old guy
talking not a theologian so you figure
it out